in the quantum bootcamp it's my pleasure
to introduce you to you even tongue
she's a peachy suit in the University of
Washington and if you follow Scott
Aaronson blog you may have come across
her name because her undergraduate
thesis was featured there which is quite
a unique feat I would say and today she
is going to hopefully tell us what to do
in case the quantum computers never come
and what do we do with all four
algorithms then so this talk I'm gonna
be giving is sort of like I guess an
overview of some recent work that I
think is kind of interesting I'm not
sure if you would need it for like a
boot camp but it's kind of nice to know
and there's a lot of interesting open
questions that I think are pretty on the
elementary side so this is gonna be
pretty similar if you were a qi p this
might be similar to that talk there's
gonna be a couple of minor variations
going to be talking a little bit more
about some classical algorithm stuff but
so first some context so this talk is
basically a classical algorithms talk
and the reason why we want to study
classical algorithms here for in this in
in this setting is that we want to
figure out when quantum algorithms give
speed ups so in like a best-case
scenario right if you have a quantum
algorithm and you ask whether it gives a
speed-up over classical algorithms you
would be like easy to decide because
maybe classical researchers have already
thought about this problem
so Shor's algorithm solves factoring
researchers have worked on factoring for
a while you know so we sort of believe
that there's like a speed-up there but
there's another situation which it's
maybe more typical which is that a
quantum algorithm doesn't solve a
problem that classical researchers work
on exactly but it sort of solves like
sort of a variance a quantum issue
variance
that's we don't know as much about so
for the example for exact example of
this h HL algorithm by Hera has cinnamon
lloyd for matrix inversion solves
systems of linear equations but it
doesn't sit in a sort of like a quantum
way that doesn't neatly translate to the
classical setting and so we need
classical algorithms research to decide
whether this actually gives the speed up
even when it looks like it might give a
speed-up compared to these algorithms
for the original problem so it's a
little vague but I'll give you an
example of quantum machine learning and
which is gonna be the focus for the rest
of the talk so I don't know if I should
I say if it needs an introduction for
why quantum machine learning might be an
interesting thing to study but basically
there are there's been a huge amount of
research into these sort of algorithms
that solve machine learning or machine
learning adjacent problems and poly
logarithmic time and dimension and so
I've listed a few there you can see that
there's it's I mean the first example is
the example I mentioned before for
matrix inversion and so you might wonder
that these are these around in time poly
logarithmic in dimension so what's the
actual nature of the speed-up
right for most machine learning problems
you have to read in the entire input in
order to do anything interesting with it
and so like if you think about the
classical problems that they solve they
take sort of linear or like polynomial
time in dimension to solve so you might
expect or you might wonder whether this
exponential gap in runtime is actually
actually actually leads to exponential
speed ups in practice if you were to for
example use one of these out loud
quantum algorithms over a classical
algorithm and so this is where classical
you can you can think about like okay
what
classical algorithms can be done for
these like quantum issue variants of
these classical problems and it turns
out that there is a quite interesting
model here of be quantized algorithms
that are able to prove that their
corresponding quantum algorithms don't
give exponential speed ups and they do
this for a wide swathe of qml algorithms
and so basically this means that even
though these poly logarithmic runtimes
seem very promising the sort of
exponential seeming runtime might only
be like a high polynomial or quadratic
or something like this yeah yeah give a
sign you say quantum machine learning is
a thing is it a good thing or bad thing
I know I'm not in the position to say to
have it take a moral stance on this I
can just say it like it's thing enos oh
I don't know it's like it's not I don't
know enough about machine learning
practice and truly safe
I only care about the asymptotics in
this setting
so yeah these new quantize algorithms
basically just prove exponential speed
ups but there is a caveat that it works
if you have the classical data to begin
with so you could think of two different
types of regimes one is quantum assume
learning on quantum data the others
quantum machine learning on classical
data we don't say anything about quantum
data or even data that's sort of like is
quantum in nature saying Hong's coming
from like circuits or things like this
we can't really say but despite this
like most machine learning pipelines
probably right now use classical data so
this still is a pretty meaningful thing
to say and so these are in red I guess
it looks kind of red are the algorithms
that I had from the previous slides that
if Indy quantized so it's like a decent
amount I guess they're uh they're few of
these that have like people had high
hopes about giving exponential speed ups
here particularly like their
recommendation systems problems and I
guess also like low rank semi definite
programming but these appear to be a
little bit more subtle issues yeah of
those you've listed and different colors
which ones required Q Ram
I think topological data analysis
doesn't in my a recoilless so if you if
you distinguish queue ram between this
like data structure that allows state
preparation versus just accessing things
in superposition the this the stronger
version i think all of them except for
topological data analysis and then maybe
this process regression but all of the
red ones used here and so so it really
depends on so some of these algorithms
are sort of unspecified in nature so you
could fill them in they do have like
state preparation assumptions that you
could fill in with Hyrum but yeah yeah
so it's not clear whether you could find
some setting in which you don't use key
RM and instead use some natural
assumption about the problem or
something
okay so that's sort of the high level of
the results so what you quantize the
algorithms actually are when you when
you sit down and look at them is that
they are just sketching algorithms in
some quantum inspired model and so
really when they come down to it it's
sort of like a there's this well-known
literature of sketching sketching
algorithms and we're just translating it
into a model that's suitable for our
purposes a model that's a little bit
more challenging and in this model we
can mimic UML algorithms or do whatever
we want to guess and I'm gonna be
talking about them in this order and
then if yeah I'll talk about the model
and then some a little bit about
classical sketching and then the rest of
the time I don't know how much time I'll
have I'll talk about some quantum
machine learning algorithms okay so what
is the model that we want to work with
well to answer that we have to study
think about like what is the model that
these qml algorithms are working in so
if we're looking at these quantum linear
algebra algorithms that run in poly log
time they basically take this this sort
of form I've given an example of matrix
inversion here where the input is a
bunch of copies of some state
corresponding to B and when I say state
corresponding to a vector I mean this
expression so the entries are the
magnitudes here and then from there
there's some algorithm that takes like
poly poly a long time to get some output
state here it's a inverse B where a is
some sparse matrix that's well
conditioned and so this is sort of like
a so this is this is basically what this
looks like and if you wanted to say
implement this on some classical data
what you would need to do is you need to
take your input and somehow prepare
efficiently prepare states corresponding
to B and then take your quantum state
corresponding to
Andrus peat and then somehow it is still
that into useful information for you and
this is and furthermore you need to do
this in if you want an exponential
speed-up you need to do this in time
that's also poly log in dimension or
else you ruin your speed up the issue is
that if you try to do this naively
you'll take polynomial time in general
yeah so your input should be some you
need to add some assumptions into your
input to allow for efficient state
preparation so like this assumption
mentioned before about here a more some
assumption of sparsity or efficient is
your ability this is some the grover
rudolph state preparation and then
output should be some like measurements
or I don't know like I swap that I don't
finish this slide I guess but yeah and
so in general this is what these
algorithms look like you have quantum
input and quantum output so how would
you compare this to a classical
algorithm the naive thing to do would be
to just compare say I get my input in
classical RAM and I want to output the
my output vector also in classical RAM
but this is sort of I'd like to argue
that this is like not the right thing to
do because this assumption that we could
efficiently prepare these input States
and then get something from this output
state is a really strong assumption and
sort of not giving classical algorithms
anything to work with would be sort of
and would leave this quad classical
model sort of underpowered basically
what I'm saying is that for any
instantiation of this quantum algorithm
in practice you have more structure than
this and so we can sort of try to guess
at what that structure could be or seems
reasonable to have and so to do this we
will consider
stronger access model than just having
input and output in RAM will consider
sample and query access which is sort of
like you can think of as an analog to a
quantum state or state preparation and
so where qml is taking this input state
to an output state will say that adi
quantized algorithm takes sample and
query access of an input to sample and
quarry access of an output and we'll be
comparing these two notions so so I'm
going to define this notion and just and
sort of the intuitive reason why it's
defined this way is that we want to
consider the case where our data is
given classically and we're not doing
anything exponentially faster when it
comes to input preparing input or
getting something from output and this
is this is reasonable because in the
quantum machine learning literature it
really is the case that not much is
happening to get to not not you don't
get much speed up out of your input and
you don't get much speed up out of
distilling your outfit and so with that
in mind we will define we will say we
have sampling query access to a vector X
if in poly log time we can query its
entries so this is informed by having
our data giving classically and we also
assume that we can sample from X or I
guess take a measurement of X in the
computational basis and this is informed
by the fact that these sort of if it's X
but if it's if it's hard to sample from
your input States already then it's sort
of like you there's your quantum machine
learning algorithm
it's not it doesn't have to do much more
in order to get an exponential speed-up
right because your your your input is
already hard to sample from so we'll
we'll take that to be easy to do and
finally just for a normalization purpose
it's cool well seem that we know it's
north when you say sample from X when
PDF here are you assuming the so
measuring from X and the computational
basis so that means sampling I with
probability X I squared
probably distribution that the data has
yeah yeah so I think I think that's
right yep rather than uniform or
something yes thank you yeah
the third assumption you could I mean if
you sample a bunch of times and then
compare that to querying some of the
entries then won't you just can't just
divide to get a good estimate of that I
think that in the worst case doesn't
mistakes
I I don't think there's a way to do it
in probably log n time always it's
advice is to have just like a constant
approximation but I still think that
even then you can't do it like if you if
you have like a uniform distribution or
something like this then maybe it would
be kind of hard to yeah I've thought
about this problem before and I didn't I
didn't figure out a way to do it
okay so I've rewritten this definition
here sample and quarry access so we have
these three abilities querying sample
and determining norm I'm going to say we
have sampling query access to a matrix
if we have sampling quarry access to all
its the rows and also sample and query
access to the vector that's just the
vector of row norms so for example if
you have a and like a quantum Ram in in
these algorithms this is the sort of
thing that you can get from it these are
those kinds of samples that you can get
from it
right and so if we're thinking of these
these input models it's just saying okay
we have our data and we also can sample
from some distributions sample or
measure some states corresponding to our
input then the question is whether these
can speed up our problem so can
classical linear algebra run in time
independence or I guess poly log in
dimension give in access to these
measurements of influence this is like
the fundamental question here and the
answer turns out to be yes and sort of
we'll we'll see why in a little bit it's
going to be basically like yeah we'll
see why and the sort of tool that we're
going to be using here is sketching so
so maybe something natural would be to
say for example if all my inputs are
like all my entries are my vectors are
have entries that are like 0 1 or minus
1 0 1 or minus 1 then this sampling just
says if you want to sample from a vector
this is just taking a nonzero entry
uniformly at random we know the number
of nonzero entries and then we can
compete we can query signs and sample
and quarry access to a matrix just means
that and we can do this and also I guess
sample rows proportional to the number
of nonzero entries in them so
yeah this is a this is a generally a
weaker assumption than most of the
assumptions for sub linear algorithms in
the setting but is that is that a good
okay
another question if I may your next
slide you use the word measurements do
you mean just the measurements you've
used in the definitions here yes
so I'm gonna be talking about a little
bit about sketching just given
high-level idea of what this what's
what's sort of the results in this field
are a standard is an example of
sketching is given here it's just one of
regression this isn't a confirm like a
the texture text book by David Woodruff
and so the problem here is that we want
to solve like regression so we have some
a some matrix a and the vector B and
then we have some we want to basically
find an epsilon approximate solution to
the least squares regression so here
this is Euclidean norm and I want to
find an X that's almost the minimizer to
ax minus B and so the the naive way to
do this is to compute or solve the
normal equations or I guess compute a
pseudo inverse B and the naive way to do
this would be ND squared runtime because
you need to invert a matrix basically
and the interesting thing is that when
you allow this epsilon approximation
then you can use the sketching algorithm
to get it down to n NZ of a which is the
number of nonzero entries of a Plus this
poly d over epsilon and when n is much
larger than D this is this might be
faster than the naive algorithm and so
the idea here is that is that suppose we
could find some s so it sets a solution
to this problem where where we just
append like a prepend s to all of these
to this expression the minimizer here is
an approximate epsilon approximate
solution to the original problem so so
say X is X is the minimizer here then X
would satisfy this property
then if s is some if FS significantly
reduces the dimension of this problem so
say if s is like Pauly D over epsilon
and further if we suppose that finding
SA and SB is fast so it takes n NZ at at
n NZ a of time then the runtime will be
exactly this quantity can you see can
you see that this is true you just if
you wanted to solve this problem this
way then what you would do is you would
just compute s ans be rate which takes
this amount of time and in the a of a
time and then you would just solve the
problem this problem instead of the
original problem and here you'll take
event D squared but instead n will be s
and so showing that such an S exists
basically goes in two parts first of all
there's some definition so a definition
that says like that of a subspace
embedding which basically says that s
has a nice approximation property namely
that s preserves all the norms of
vectors in the the column space of a and
then an observation that this suffice is
to give an epsilon approximate solution
so if s is a subspace embedding for this
for a with be appended to it then X will
be the desired solution that we want and
this is actually not not too hard to see
but although gloss over it for now and
then what uses what you observe is that
there is actually such a embedding
matrix a subspace embedding and it has
the desired number of rows and it can be
computed in the desired time so this is
just an example of what's going on in
sketching more generally there is so
there's like a so to solve our problem
we showed some property that suffices
for
I say to be a good problem reduction
from a so this was this substation
betting property and then secondly we
showed a sketch that satisfies the
property namely this sparse embedding
thing that I mentioned and sketching
algorithms just kind of kind of alright
just do this for a whole wide range of
problems and they do it for a wide
variety of different sketches and
problems and things like this and so why
am I talking about this yeah sorry yeah
so a this is a random matrix and it
satisfies the probability with good
probability right so so why am I talking
about this well this is what we are able
to do what what these algorithms are
able to do is they're able to take
things of large dimension and then do
some sort of reduction and then solve a
problem of small dimension that suffice
is for the original problem and so in
our setting where we care about taking
time independence of dimension right it
seems useful that we could use these
techniques to sort of reduce dimension
and eventually solve our our qml problem
and indeed like these problems these
things have been looked at before in the
context of quantum algorithms yeah so so
these things have been looked at in the
intersection of quantum before but we
run into an issue here for our quantum
inspired setting because we can't
actually use any of these sketches
because they take time that's like
linear and dimension to a find and apply
so what we'll do instead is recall that
we we allowed ourselves to have these
measurements to our input states certain
measurements to input States and we can
actually just use this to do our own
types of sketches and it's a well-known
observation actually that these kinds of
measurements do work well as as sketches
so they speed up machine learning and
linear algebra and this is called like
important sampling in the sketching
literature so specifically what I mean
is that I call s an important sampling
sketch of a if s is rows are chosen
independently at random and they look
like this what I mean here is that if I
look at si the eighth row is formed by
sampling a row proportional sampling a
row proportional to Rho norm squared so
this is measuring a tilde from that
definition previously and then setting
si that the row two
so it is that that row with some
renormalization so si would have the
idea of si would have norm for being
nice number of a over spirit
and so there are a couple of things to
observe about this sketch first of all
if we have sampling Cory access to a
then we can find si in time independent
of dimension so so if s is small here if
we are looking at a very small sketch
and we can find si quickly because it's
just a normalized subset of rows all you
need to do is you need to just take a
bunch of measurements from a tilde and
this will give you your sketch this is
way faster than all of the other
sketches that we wrote that this is
faster than all of it all the other
sketches in this setting and another
thing to notice is that as I mentioned
before the I throw of Si is the same
thing for all the rows of AI and what
this means is that we can we can get
sampling quarry access to s a tilde
great so we note no all the row norms of
Si basically and so we can just sample
from the corresponding state just by
picking an entry uniformly at random and
what this means is that given sampling
quarry access to a we can simulate
samples ambulatory access to si picking
some of the is it column you're picking
subset of rows at random and then
scaling them scaling them up but so as
as I thinking about it as a robot
yes rose yeah so yeah to get this you
basically just have to think about it
for a little bit so you can get sampling
Cree access to si and you can also get a
sampling quarry access to its transpose
if s is sufficiently small I don't know
of a super easy way of seeing this but
what this is is you want sampling quarry
access to the columns of Si and si is
essays columns are small so you can just
do that naively and then you you just
need the sample to be able to sample
appropriately which you can get from
sampling to this different really but in
any case what these two things mean is
that if we have sampling query access to
our input we can sketch things down
without taking time in dimension and
when we sketch them down we sketch them
down in such a way that we can't we have
sampling quarry access to the things
that we - - are sketched inputs right so
we can just keep iterating this over and
over again and then and so so we can
just we can we can just apply this as
many times as advance so that that's
that's that's the that's the instance of
our sketch so as for our property what
we're going to use is that we're going
to use that important sampling can
approximate matrix products so this is
the full statement of the thing which
basically says that if we have sampling
query access to a and B then if I sketch
a and B down then it sketch them down to
a size that's independent of them
then I basically approximating this
matrix product up to some Frobenius norm
additive error so it's um yeah this
epsilon could be nice or a for being
sort of beat I better and since
s/insp again are normalized sub matrices
of an be we have sample and quarry
access to like all of Si and ice P and
then there's transposes so this is like
the full statement of the theorem if you
kind of want to see why this is true you
can consider the case where a and B are
equal in this case you only need
sampling for access to a and to see why
this approximation works kind of what's
happening is that we can write out a
dagger a as a sum of outer products so
here AI are the rows of a and so we can
write a dagger a as a sum of outer
products of each of the rows and so if I
think about the sketch s what the sketch
s is doing is its sampling a row
proportional to the row norm squared so
and and sort of taking that as your
estimator and so if you think about what
it's doing in this context sampling from
the row norm squared is equivalent to
picking one of these picking one of
these six these outer products and with
probability proportional to its weight
in this sum right and taking that to be
your estimator and then yeah so and
taking this for as larger is just taking
the mean of a bunch of these instances
and it's not it's a and and to get
concentration from there you use like a
martingale inequality or something but
this is just at a high level this is
what's going on when you're looking at
this si dagger SB quantity
and so we have our approximate matrix
product of like property that our
sketches have and so suppose that we had
sampling query access to some input and
we wanted to compute some output what we
can do is we could write the output as a
formula based on the input and then just
while the expression is still too hard
for me to compute I could just use this
theorem to reduce some matrix dimensions
to independent of size of input and I
just do this over and over and over
again and it turns out this is sort of
like the meta algorithm works for
speeding up speeding up these linear
algebra problems and the client so when
you do this you'll eventually come up
with a result that takes time
independence of dimension and the errors
will propagate to give some sort of like
Frobenius norm type error and sort of
some sort of think of this for being
some error as being large if your input
is high rank and well-conditioned and
small if your input is low rank and so
you this sort of like reflects the fact
that these classical algorithms can't
sort of exploit these sketching
algorithms can't exploit the structure
of like unit aires and things like this
just like high-level intuition here but
the issue is that despite this fact that
they don't really seem to like you do
lose a lot by taking this instead of a
quantum algorithm many quantum
algorithms actually do pick up this
error somewhere and in particular the
ones that don't use this h HL this
quantities the quantum machine learning
algorithms that don't use this type of
sparse matrix inversion type thing will
incur that and then we can be quantized
such algorithms
so for the rest of the time I'll try to
figure it I'll try to talk about this
recommendation systems example on the
board are there any questions about what
I just said
so
I'm going to be talking about the
their recommendation systems problem
this is a quantum algorithm given by
Kara nitta-san precaution 2017 and the
idea here is that somehow we assume that
we have a matrix a and this sort of
reflects the data that we have about
users and products and what users feel
about products and then what the
algorithm does is it take this a that's
somehow and in key in some sort of
quantum Ram
and from there it constructs a quantum
state corresponding side row of a then
it uses many uses some phase estimation
argument to gets a quantum state courts
finding VI where D
reviews a low-rank approximation of a I
think so so lowering approximation you
can see think about it as a function on
the singular values of a so this is
actually you can actually use singular
value transformation here that on Josh
talked about and then from there you
measure to get your to get some index
and the hope is that this index is a
good recommendation for that particular
user so more formally the problem that
we want to consider is that we have
sampling query access say this is a
corresponding assumption to a being a
QAM and we want to get sampling query
access to di where again diesel or
approximation of a more specifically
what I want is
what I want is about a half Ford is
better yeah so okay so first of all um
I'm gonna be using the singular value
decomposition of a right so this is
writing a is your Sigma transpose where
you wouldn't be your unitary big most
diagonal
and it's diagonal entries are the
singular values and they're non-negative
and I'm going to use the singular value
transformation definition so if I if I
look at a function sort of the function
from the reals to the complex numbers
then when I talk about applying this to
a matrix I'm just going to mean can
people see this means I'm applying F to
each of the singular values
so the definition I'm going to use here
is that the eye is closed - I'm gonna
call this some threshold function of a
and then once he of a looks like a
matrix or a rose sorry okay the eye is a
row of a d so when you were when you're
doing the so somehow you're doing this
is the matrix level like in the
recommendation line above but then if
you're interested in a specific user you
then like measure the I throw whatever
comes out just to understand what you
were writing at the very beginning so
here part of the input is a user which
is an index I hear ya and ya so so this
transformation uses more about a than
just the Specter yeah right so that's
happening and then somehow at the end
you're just measuring something
interesting yes
if you want you can also consider this
to be times some vector that would be
fine I think
yeah so this tea I'm going to write it
what's happening here
so what it's doing is tea is throwing
away all of the small singular values
and then preserving all of the the
singular values that are at least stigma
so this is supposed to be the identity
and then
it is sort of between region we sort of
allow it to be anything we're okay with
it being anything in this so we want to
say that bee is close to one of these
singular Valley transformations this is
but it's anything at all or anything in
a range anything between zero and four
being a sort of a ah between zero okay
so we want to okay so so this is the
problem we're gonna solve and then what
we're going to use I'm just gonna write
this down is our technique that if we
have sampling quarry access to s into a
and sampling quarry access to B then
then a B is well approximated
we'll approximated by si
proximate things in this
this is
okay so are we gonna do this what we can
do is we can write T of a
this product we can write it as a times
what I'm gonna call P of a transpose hey
I'm working in the reals and also
daggers look like pseudo-inverse since I
know what and what P is is it's going to
be like a projector so this is like a
low-rank approximation and this is sort
of the projector onto the large singular
values that's the idea and so
here what's going to happen is that our
function is zero for small values one
for large values and in between it's a
linear interpolation
and notice that these values on the
x-axis are squares of these values
because applying it to a transpose a so
the singular values are squared right so
you might be able to see but this
satisfies our definition here of us of
our Laura proximation that we want and
furthermore this is nicer than this
because I've written in a way that we
can approximate alright so we have
sampling query access to a so we can
approximate this I'm gonna write
everything out you can see the
dimensions
sorry why don't we get like a you know
these singular values getting cubed when
you do this so like you're not in you
are you inverting somehow so so if you
think about a singular vector with
singular value I erase the sorry Sigma
sorry larger than Sigma then this will
contribute Sigma and then this will be
Sigma squared so it will contribute one
oh it's one sorry sorry
okay so this is good Weaver do some
dimensions and now what we can do we can
rewrite it so we can reduce more
dimensions so I'm gonna rewrite this
you are and
I'm just gonna define P bar to be P of X
over X so why is this true you can think
of this if si was a scalar this would be
P of s a squared and this is P bar of s
a squared times si squared you can see
this sort of tracks in the general case
what you would do is you'd write si out
as its singular value decomposition and
then just verify that these are the same
so we've rewritten this in a way where
we can do more approximating
so then I'm gonna say we apply sketch 2
here we have sampling core access to
this guy and also did this guy so we can
get
and then I'm going to do it one more
time
wait
so here I reduced the dimension down to
independence of this should be small
so
and I'm going to do one final
approximation here
these are all sketches I guess I guess I
can write it down
these three sketches here and now all
three of these are independent of
dimensions and so I and these are all
sub matrices of a and I can compute them
easily so yeah so I can compute their
singular value decomposition to apply
the P for example and so I'm just gonna
call this collectively the matrix here Z
and if we want to approximate something
that's like T of a this is like the best
I can do
right this is we need this dimension
because our information is tall and we
need this dimension because we need we
need this dimension stupid joke okay so
so I haven't really tried to argue that
these approximations give you the
desired cubes the desired error I can
either talk about that or finish up the
algorithm pretty their algorithm
you can just compute these errors you
can you can do it like the naive thing
will get you the right answer okay so
it turns out that this
a that most Epsilon
salon for beanies thermal okay and here
I'm choosing and there's also a factor
there's also factors here of ravine you
storms over statements the quantum
algorithm assumes that this is intended
as dimension so we can rescale epsilon
by this to get the desired found okay
and then finally we want to sample from
di you know because the desired form and
what this is is VI is equal to so I'm
taking this and I'm looking at the I
throw this is equivalent to looking at
the I throw of this guy and then
multiplying it through so this is a
small thing
and you can see that what we want to do
well formally we want to get sampling
query access to this it turns out that
the hard party that's sampling here and
the way you do this so so what I've
tried to argue is that it suffice is to
show that if we have sampling query
access to a bunch of vectors
then I can get sampling for access
and just sorry doing this you use
rejection sampling it's basically just a
computation but for some intuition yeah
what I want to get so if you consider
the case where the lambda eyes are just
one it's actually without loss of
generality you can assume this because
you can rescale the beads it suffice is
to sort of figure out two distributions
a distribution that's close to the one
that you want so what we want is s a
sample s with probability
what we want is this sum and what we can
get is the probability distribution that
is
so what we can get is this distribution
what this distribution is is we sample a
vector uniformly at random or sorry
proportional to its norm and norm
squared and then we sample from it this
is this distribution and the only
difference between these two is that one
of them it has interference you know
basically this parenthesis alone is on
the outside so you can have negative
values that affect things here and this
one you don't but it turns out that
because you're only working with K
vectors here you can accommodate you can
account for this the so I guess I'm out
of time so I should just say so if you
follow this through and do everything do
all the analysis here this gives you
actually the the best runtime that we
know how to do for this kind of problem
so actually just doing this like naive
thing where you just hit things with
sketches over and over just kind of
works but it still gives a really high
polynomial something like there's like a
six and a 10 something like this and so
it's not clear whether you can do
something more clever to speed this up
hopefully this is like a simple enough
idea that you can sort of understand it
[Applause]